[Music]
it is the biggest welcome the nation can
provide
[Music]
ceremonial spectacle of a state visit
and greeting the president of South
Africa the King on the world stage for
the first time as head of state
it's a diplomatic day of careful
choreography
a guard of Honor for Cyril ramaphosa
for a carriage procession to Buckingham
Palace
and inside another display a viewing of
South African artifacts from the Royal
collection including a chess set from
Nelson Mandela
the king leading the tour but supported
by his family
these visits are a chance to reset
relationships
and a chance for the president to escape
domestic pressures he's facing Rising
unemployment daily power cuts and
allegations of corruption but here he
represents a vital trading partner and
that's the focus for the government the
ties between our two countries and
Nations
are old and enduring we therefore see
this visit as an opportunity to
celebrate our modern relationship
as equal partners
working together for the prosperity and
security of our people
[Applause]
the royal red carpets have been rolled
out but behind the Pomp and pageantry
there is a purpose this is soft power
working hard to build Bridges and
restore relations
it's a big moment for the king the first
date visit of his Reign and a speech to
a key member of the Commonwealth Laura
bundock Sky News at Buckingham Palace